[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
la península de corea está que arde y
los tambores de guerra con su atronador
sonido retumban sin parar
si es verdad no es que esta zona del
mundo sea por lo general precisamente
tranquila pero lo cierto es que hacía
mucho que no se vivía tanta tensión eeuu
que ya tenía unos 30.000 soldados en la
zona ha desplegado además varios
portaaviones bombarderos ve uno ve con
capacidad nuclear e incluso un avanzado
sistema antimisiles en corea del sur tan
avanzado que china lo ha considerado
como una amenaza para su propia
seguridad china pide la suspensión
inmediata del escudo antimisiles de eeuu
en corea del sur corea del norte por su
parte no cesa de realizar nuevas pruebas
con misiles balísticos y de avanzar en
su programa nuclear si a corea del norte
le da igual hacer volar por los aires
toda la legislación internacional sobre
proliferación y ensayos nucleares japón
y corea del sur por su parte se
preguntan estos días muy tensos qué
pasos seguir y qué decisiones tomar para
tratar de frenar la creciente amenaza
que cada vez más representa la agresiva
conducta del régimen de kim
entonces no me estresaba dunst con
indignación lo vimos hace poco aquí en
visual político japonés está
considerando muy en serio poner fin de
una vez por todas al carácter pacifista
de su constitución
[Música]
e
e incluso todo apunta porque esta vez es
completamente diferente a otra quien
pekín empiezan a estar hasta el gorro de
pyongyang sin desplegar a cien mil
soldados en su frontera con corea del
norte vamos que si todo esto fuese una
película saldría del cine pensando que
al guionista se le fue la mano con la
dosis de ficción timer me vaya
fuego
ahora bien qué está pasando qué podemos
esperar vamos a verlo en este vídeo pero
antes de nada cobramos un poco de
perspectiva
[Música]
dónde estamos y cómo hemos llegado hasta
aquí
corea del norte es una especie de
pesadilla del pasado un país que vive en
plena guerra fría que padece uno de los
gobiernos más totalitarios del mundo y
que además es uno de los países más
pobres del planeta según naciones
unidas- dos de cada cinco norcoreanos
sufren desnutrición claro que eso parece
importarle poco o nada a kim jong-un el
tipo que controla el país con mano de
hierro
pues bien se calcula que pyongyang
comenzó a desarrollar su programa de
armas nucleares allá por los años 80 y
desde entonces ha vivido tres momentos
clave que han acelerado sustancialmente
su desarrollo la caída de la unión
soviética en 1991
la inclusión de corea del norte por
george bush- en el llamado 'eje del mal'
en el 2002 y la llegada de kim jong-un
al poder en 2011 vamos podemos decir que
cada vez que el régimen se sintió
amenazado que hizo el acelerador pero
esto lo vamos a ver un poco más tarde el
caso es que a día de hoy se estima que
corea del norte tiene entre 10 y 20
armas nucleares y según la corporación
rand de no pararse el programa corea del
norte podrá llegar a tener en 2020 unas
100 bombas nucleares pero esperad un
momento porque aquí no acaba todo
de momento la tecnología que utiliza
este país es cómo decirlo rudimentaria
en tanto en cuanto deriva de viejos
diseños de la etapa de la unión
soviética lo que hace que las bombas que
corea del norte ha desarrollado hasta
ahora sean
poco operativas tienen visión
por eso el régimen de kim jong-un el
régimen de pyongyang tiene actualmente
dos obsesiones por un lado conseguir
miniaturizar estas bombas es decir me
explico reducir su tamaño para poder
ensamblar las en misiles
por otro desarrollar misiles balísticos
capaces de atacar objetivos a miles de
kilómetros de distancia
y ojo amigos las últimas pruebas
muestran avances muy importantes en este
objetivo
muchos analistas incluidos los servicios
de inteligencia de corea del sur y eeuu
consideran que corea del norte tiene ya
capacidad para equipar con cabezas
nucleares misiles de corto y medio
alcance lo que le permitiría alcanzar
corea del sur y japón
y esto no es todo parece bastante claro
que de no pararse el programa en pocos
años corea del norte podría conseguir la
capacidad de atacar con misiles
balísticos a los mismísimos eeuu lo que
ya de entrada supone como os podéis
imaginar un gran salto estratégico y
esto os aseguro es una línea roja que
genera muchos muchos dolores de cabeza
en el pentágono
ahora bien puede que os estáis
preguntando pero es que eeuu no ha hecho
nada para frenar a este país pues lo
cierto es que ha hecho casi de todo
la estrategia de eeuu durante años tanto
eeuu como corea del sur han tratado de
convencer a pyongyang de que abandonasen
su plan para desarrollar armas nucleares
y para ello la verdad no han tenido
reparo en tirar de talonario a
principios de los 90 concretamente en
1994 bill clinton firmó el llamado
acuerdo macro por el que corea del norte
se comprometió a suspender su plan
militar a cambio de recibir de eeuu una
generosa ayuda en combustible y la
asistencia para construir dos reactores
nucleares para uso civil es decir con
este plan corea del norte conseguía la
energía necesaria para poder desarrollar
su economía por su parte corea del sur
además de entregar ingentes cantidades
de ayuda humanitaria se comprometió
también a impulsar y financiar programas
de desarrollo económico en su vecino del
norte como zonas industriales y todo
parecía muy bonito al menos bueno para
todas las partes sin embargo en 2000
todo se vino abajo cuando george bush-
se enteró de que pyongyang le había
estado tomando el pelo a washington
corea del norte continuaba desarrollando
en secreto su programa nuclear para usos
militares pues bien tras varias tiras y
aflojas en 2007 se llegó a un nuevo
acuerdo y la administración bush
reinicio la entrega de ayuda y levantó
sanciones pero al poco tiempo tan sólo
un año después
pyongyang rechazó seguir adelante
a pesar de todo barack obama lo volvió a
intentar y en febrero de 2012 se llegó a
un nuevo acuerdo por el que corea del
norte- suspendía su programa y eeuu se
iniciaba otra vez las ayudas económicas
esta vez pyongyang rompió el acuerdo
sólo seis semanas después llegados a
este punto puede que os estáis
preguntando por qué tanto empeño en
tener armas nucleares
[Música]
que buscan las partes el régimen de kim
jong-un lo tiene muy claro y amigos
hagámonos a la idea corea del norte y no
se va a desprender de su programa
nuclear porque primero porque lo
considera indispensable para su
supervivencia
kim jong-un y la élite que gobierna
corea del norte sabe que con armas
nucleares de por medio ninguna potencia
extranjera especialmente eeuu se
atreverá a intervenir en el país
cuando estados unidos invadió irak los
líderes norcoreanos tomaron nota para
ellos el principal error de sadam husein
fue no estar equipado con bombas
nucleares y armas de destrucción masiva
[Música]
lo mismo pensaron cuando cayó el régimen
de gadafi en libia que unos años antes
en 2003 había desmantelado
voluntariamente su programa para
desarrollar armas de destrucción masiva
[Música]
es decir los líderes norcoreanos piensan
y probablemente tengan razón que las
armas nucleares son hoy por hoy su mejor
garantía para continuar en el poder por
otro lado la venta de equipos militares
es una de las principales fuentes de
divisas del país divisas necesarias para
que los gerifaltes puedan mantener su
tren de vida pues bien atentos desde que
cayó la unión soviética corea del norte
se ha convertido en uno de los
principales exportadores de equipos
tecnología y componentes de misiles la
armada española intercepta en yemen un
buque norcoreano con misiles scud
asimismo todo apunta a que este país ha
vendido también tecnología nuclear a
irán y que ha asistido así en la
construcción del reactor nuclear que
israel bombardeó en 2007 israel ataca
siria y destruye un reactor nuclear
precisamente este riesgo de
proliferación es una de las grandes
motivaciones que eeuu tiene para tratar
de frenar a corea del norte
la otra gran motivación evidentemente es
impedir que este país tenga capacidad
para amenazarle con armas nucleares
pero dicho esto y china que piensa china
de todo esto
[Música]
china
una cosa tenemos que tener muy clara si
en el apoyo de china corea del norte
nunca nunca habría llevado a cabo su
programa nuclear y no sólo por lo que se
refiere a la parte tecnológica o al
apoyo para evitar las sanciones
internacionales sino también por el
dinero más del 90 por ciento del
comercio de corea del norte es con china
en otras palabras sin el apoyo de pekín
hace ya tiempo que este país hubiese
colapsado ahora bien hay claros indicios
de que pekín empieza a estar un poco
hasta las narices de tanta provocación y
lo de los misiles nucleares tampoco
parece hacerles mucha gracia
tal vez se pueda decir que para la china
de xi jinping pyongyang ha pasado de ser
un elemento de presión a un lastre ahora
que china quiere ganar peso y liderado
la agenda internacional china se erige
como la defensora del libre mercado y
enemigo del proteccionismo en la cumbre
apec de lima ojo por su parte otros
analistas han llegado a plantear que
pekín puede estar perdiendo control
sobre el gobierno de corea del norte
ensimismado
o poder nuclear el caso es que por
primera vez en noviembre de 2016 china
suscribió plenamente las sanciones
internacionales contra corea del norte
por si fuese poco en los últimos meses
china ha prohibido la importación de
carbón desde corea del norte y la
exportación de gas a este país lo que en
círculos internacionales ha generado
cierta expectación he estado un castigo
al régimen de kim jong y aún más las
relaciones diplomáticas entre ambos
países están en su peor momento de hecho
desde que kim jong-un llegase al poder
no se ha celebrado ningún encuentro
bilateral al máximo nivel y las visitas
oficiales de altos funcionarios entre
ambos gobiernos se han desplomado será
que pekín está cambiando su relación con
pyongyang
[Música]
camino a una solución
aún es pronto amigos pero desde luego
que nadie se llame a engaño de momento
china no va a dejar caer a corea del
norte que sigue siendo su único gran
aliado militar en la región al menos
mientras no existan contrapartidas de
peso y tal vez este sea el punto clave
si queremos encontrar una salida a esta
crisis digámoslo claro hay que convencer
al xi jinping de que haga desistir a kim
jong-un de sus empeños de que suspenda
el programa nuclear norcoreano y de que
lleve a cabo reformas reales esto es
algo que nunca se va a conseguir con
coacción así que muchos expertos
defienden que ha llegado la hora de
plantear el repliegue de las tropas de
eeuu en corea poner sobre la mesa el
desmantelamiento del sistema antimisiles
y también otras contrapartidas
económicas todo siempre y cuando claro
esta china consiga frenar a corea del
norte por si acaso tal vez convendría
dejar claro a pekín que la situación
actual abre la vía para que corea del
sur y japón puedan querer explorar no
sólo la vía de la carrera armamentística
sino también ojo
las armas nucleares en cualquier caso
este es un rompecabezas con difícil
solución y como ya nos alertaba nuestro
amigo martín hace muy poquito tiempo en
nuestro mundo aún hay demasiadas armas
nucleares por cierto si quieres saber
más sobre este tema te dejo un link al
final del vídeo turno para vosotros
amigos pinchad aquí para dejarnos
vuestra opinión en esta encuesta qué
pasos crees que debe dar la
administración trama debe dejar a corea
del norte proseguir con su siniestro
plan nuclear a amenazarles con la guerra
o explorar la vía china publicaremos los
resultados en nuestra cuenta de twitter
de visual política así que no te olvides
de seguirnos como siempre si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo pulgares
arriba dale a like y suscríbete al canal
si aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]
e
bueno
ah
e